romania has one of the highest covert 19
death rates in the world
what will it take to stop the spread of
the virus in a country where thousands
are against containment measures
including vaccinations
nearly 400 romanians are dying from the
virus every day
the health system is collapsing
ambulances are queuing outside hospitals
already at capacity
some covert patients are being
transferred to neighboring hungry for
treatment
welcome i'm ben fazoulen another uh
point we should point out is that
romania has one of the european union's
lowest vaccination rates only a third of
adults are fully vaccinated with over 16
000 daily infections the president has
described the situation as catastrophic
in rural areas vaccine hesitancy is
strong especially in the southern town
of que este
dw correspondent funny fachab paid a
visit to an area where hospitals are
overwhelmed and understaffed
the more rural it gets the more people
are reluctant to get the job in romania
we are in the town of cayeshti there are
currently over 90 covet patients in the
local hospital and only four doctors
lorenzio belushika is one of them his
enemy time
takes us to the red zone with film with
the hospital's phone to reduce the risk
of contamination
inside a red zone there is a lack of
everything especially oxygen i need 150
every day and how much do you have
25 25 everything i think
he and his team can do little for the
patients there is a lack of medicine and
personnel 95 percent of those who end up
here are unvaccinated many die
rural areas in romania have been hit
hard by covet but there is little trust
in the vaccine or in the government
conspiracy theories arrive and reasons
to refuse the vaccine vary
no survivor i'm not vaccinated i am
against it because i don't believe in
the virus
i didn't make a decision yet i'm waiting
i don't know for how long
the dramatic upsurge in cases and a
rolling average of 300 people dying each
day more people have turned up at
vaccination centers in the capital
bucharest to get their shot but it's not
enough to turn the situation around
currently only one third of the
population has been vaccinated romania
was off to a promising start but
vaccination slowed down exposing
millions to the virus
about 14 of bucharest's population is
infected with covet 19 and that number
keeps rising especially amongst the
unvaccinated population now despite that
many people remain skeptical of the
vaccines
state officials want to find a way out
of the crisis but how
right now what we can do is to increase
highly increase the vaccination rate for
instance if you get vaccinated with a
vaccine that is administered in one
single dose that means that in 14 days
you'll be having
maximal immunity
for lorenzio balushika and so many
chronically underfunded hospitals it's
all too little too late
i'm tired
maybe
not maybe
for sure a little discouraged
maintains the pandemic is still not
being taken seriously by the authorities
we don't have enough oxygen or funds for
medication and soon the fifth wave will
be here
the ambulances continue to arrive with
covet patients even though there aren't
enough beds to take care of them
is intensive catchy physician at
floresca hospital in bucharest the
biggest emergency hospital in the
country what is it like on the front
line of this battle what have you
experienced with patients who've turned
down the vaccine but end up in in your
hospital in a serious or
life-threatening situation
it is very sad to see a lot of patients
coming to the hospital with severe form
of the disease and we know that more
than 93 percent of the patient admitted
in the icu were unvaccinated people
unfortunately in these fourth waves of
kovid
disease we have a lot of young
young people
that come in the hospital
on sunday we admitted in the icu a young
male 29 years old with a severe form of
covid19 unvaccinated the patient
required the intubation and mechanical
ventilation it's very sad and
frustrating for us
to fight against this disease but
unfortunately the patients that develop
severe form
are totally
unvaccinated patients it's very sad
because now we have we have the
opportunity to stop the pandemic in
romania but we don't use the vaccine
because we don't trust in existence of
the virus we don't trust in vaccine we
trust in the conspiration theory and
that will increase the number of deaths
unfortunately
um did did that guy manage to survive
yes he is still in the icu intubated
mechanical ventilated he received
antiviral therapy and we hope that we
can save him but this patient
is in this situation because
he was unvaccinated we know
from now that all the patients who
develop severe disease are unvaccinated
and we know unfortunately only 20
of uh patients with
age more than 80 years old are were
vaccinated in romania and we know this
kind of patient will develop for sure a
severe form of kovite 19 when he when
they will uh be contaminated with the
sarskoff to do
and the fact that romania has one of the
highest covert death rates in the world
isn't enough to convince the doubters
yes or no we observed that in the
previous days a lot of
people wants to be vaccinated but
unfortunately still 40 of the population
they are not convinced about the
benefits of vaccination but we pay a
huge tribute to convince them to be
vaccinated more than 400 people die
every day here
and it's a huge pay to convince people
to be vaccinated
because in summer in a summer holiday we
have a very good situation and a lot of
people can
come here to be vaccinated by they
refuse to receive the vaccine but
winter's coming now and the hospitals
are not well equipped
you've worked abroad how is the
situation there because some health
professionals call the situation
depressing and i don't know i wouldn't
want to catch covet and then end up in
one of the hospitals there
difficult because uh
our critical care beds are uh
fully occupied now and i we have a lot
of patient uh
remains in the emergency department and
stayed there for uh 10 days or longer to
wait uh bad for the icu it's very
difficult because our national capacity
in the icu it's
a little bit more than 4 000 bets and
now we use half of this capacity to
treat a patient with covid19 and the
rest of the beds 2000 we use it to treat
all the patients with all the disease
and it will be very difficult if the
patient is called being 19 will increase
in the next period because they will
because we need more capacity to treat
this patient and
unfortunately a lot of other patients
will
will come with difficulty in the icu
okay you heard it from tinkle romania's
fluoresce hospital there thank you very
much for being on the program today
over to derek williams now for another
of your questions a good one if you're
keen to get back on that treadmill after
recovering from covet
how long should i wait after
19 symptoms disappear to resume
exercising
this is a tricky question because while
there are obvious health benefits to
exercise there are also potential
hazards involved in starting to work out
again
too soon after an illness especially if
you were seriously sick
or are experiencing longer term effects
and we're still learning about the
hazards associated with postcovid health
so
so this is a decision that definitely
needs to be made in consultation with
your doctor
that said
i did read some cautious study-based
advice from for example the mayo clinic
that says that if you test positive for
covet 19
but then had only very low-grade
symptoms or no symptoms at all
you can start with basic low-level
stretching and muscular exercise
about a week after your symptoms subside
and then slowly work your way on from
there
but don't push it
what i highly recommend for anyone who's
recovered from covet 19 is to read a
leaflet on
rehabilitation that's published by the
world health organization
which provides some some excellent
advice and simple rules as you try to
strike the right balance between
getting back in form as quickly as
possible but in a safe way
the leaflet also illustrates a series of
basic exercises
that anyone can do with very little
equipment so they can be performed
almost anywhere
as i said though make a plan with your
doctor and bear in mind
that no matter how ill you got from
covet 19 it's going to take time
maybe a lot of time to get back into the
shape that you were in
before you caught it
after what we heard from that doctor in
romania earlier healthcare workers must
be exhausted from the pandemic and
another stressful winter is definitely
not what the doctor ordered that's why
hospital staff in austria gathered to
protest for a higher vaccination rate
with messages like we are at the limit
get your jab or facts instead of fake
news they prompted their fellow citizens
to do their part in easing the crisis
nice to have you along stay safe and see
you again soon
[Music]
you